[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM FEINER: We've
all been there.
You're on call, in charge
of an entire production
system such as this.
It's peak traffic
on the East Coast,
but you're on the other
side of the world,
sleeping like a baby.
You have no idea what's
about to hit you.
In my nightmares,
here's what I see.
The pager goes off saying
something like this.
You wipe the sleep
from your eyes,
grab a computer to investigate.
You're still half
asleep and have
no idea what's really going on.
Traffic jams are forming
all around the area.
Users have no idea where
to go to avoid traffic.
Time to start debugging.
Millions of people
are counting on you.
You open the CPU graph
for this server group,
as you know the
service is CPU bound.
And it looks normal.
All the scaling did its thing.
It was set to keep
the CPU under 45%.
And that's exactly what it did.
The number of instances doubled
when the CPU started to climb.
So why isn't the
service working?
You feel a cold sweat forming.
This is not going to end well.
All instances in
this server group
are currently completely
failing their health checks.
You connect to a
sample server, and you
see that it's at 100% CPU.
Why?
Pick a jstack, and nothing comes
to you, can't see anything.
So you restart the
application, look at the logs,
just to see the
start-up sequence,
see if you can find anything.
But it all looks fine.
The dependencies are loading.
The application starts fine.
But yet, once it's started,
CPU jumps right back to 100%.
A bad feeling creeps up
your spine at this point.
You connect to another server,
and this one's completely idle.
How come?
You look around,
and you can't even
find the application
running there at all.
What's going on here?
Was the CPU graph from
earlier lying to me?
CPU graphs usually don't lie.
You check it again,
and you realize,
it's an average CPU graph.
How did I miss that?
So it appears, that some
servers are running at 100% CPU,
burning up, practically
thrashing, not doing anything,
while others are
completely idle.
So you ask yourself,
am I in over my head?
Your heart tries to pound
its way out of your chest
when you realize you have
no idea how to fix this.
Then, while looking at the
logs, suddenly, instance
gets terminated, thrown out.
And you can't debug anymore.
In the UI, you see
even more instances
committing suicide,
instances which were just
started a few minutes ago.
This doesn't make any sense.
The system's scaled up, only
to kill itself in the loop?
Come on.
Is it time to admit failure?
Wake up some other people
from the team to help?
You're supposed to know
what you're doing here.
You're a professional.
You think for a minute.
What on Earth could
be causing this?
And nothing comes to mind.
OK, OK.
So you pick up the phone,
about to call for help.
You're about to hit Send.
Then it hits you.
That's auto-healing.
Auto-healing is like
the immune system,
it's supposed to replace
unhealthy instances.
But in this case,
it's all of them,
so it's doing much
more harm than good.
You dig through
the console to try
to find out where to
shut down auto-healing,
wasting a few more
precious minutes.
You find another server
which is still up and idle.
Why is the application
not running there?
You keep combing the
logs, trying to find--
you're looking
everywhere you can,
till you finally find this.
Apparently, each
server, upon startup,
connects to a
configuration server
to download this configuration.
Without it, it's
pretty much useless.
So this configuration
server, apparently
fell over and managed to do
two things at the same time.
One, it's taking down this
entire production system
with it, turning a perfectly
nice auto-scaling group
into a set of zombie servers
which are committing suicide.
And two, is to give
you a heart attack.
Now that you
understand the problem,
you quickly fix the
configuration server,
scale up some more servers,
and we're back to normal [SIGH]
finally.
You double check, just to
make sure, and go back to bed,
patting yourself on the
back for saving the day.
You try to sleep, but
find it impossible.
Something's still bothering you.
Did we really save the day?
We were down for 20 minutes.
20 minutes with millions
of users frustrated.
Then you realize, your
job is not to be a ninja,
even though it's fun sometimes.
Your job is to
prevent these kind
of failures in the first place.
You remember hearing once about
the immutable server pattern,
and a light pops
up in your head.
If this fleet of servers
was immutable and completely
self-contained, all of this
would have been avoided.
Baking eliminates the
external dependencies
such as this
configuration server,
improving the stability of
the system, not to mention
faster boot times.
So you wake up in the
morning and run off
to work to start baking
immutable images.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVEN KIM: There is an
astronaut saying in space
"there is no problem so bad
that you can't make it worse."
And it speaks to dealing
with a level of complexity
and pressure like in this story,
where you can quickly feel
like you're in sinking sand.
The complexity of rolling out
software continues to increase.
New architectures,
micro-services architecture,
the scope of deployment,
multi-regional deployments,
global deployments.
And, as a response,
what we've done,
is we've introduced measures
and processes that slow us down.
And I think, at this
point, most of us
don't think that rolling
out the production
hourly, daily, weekly, monthly,
quarterly is a good idea,
let alone feasible.
And meanwhile,
what's on the table,
is early and often feedback that
we're doing the right things,
frequent opportunities
to pivot and change
direction when we need to, and
some side effects of doing more
frequent roll-outs, such
as the scope of change
is smaller because you're
doing more frequently,
so there is
inherently less risk.
So there's a lot
of talk out there
about continuous delivery.
But we need to talk
about really what's
important in terms
of first principles
behind continuous delivery
and not just the tooling.
And Google's been
doing this a long time.
We have made our
share of mistakes.
We have lessons learned.
And based on that, we
have a set of opinions.
So we want to go to share
those lessons learned
with you, along with
some tangible examples.
Continuous delivery can't just
be about better orchestration.
It's one of the things,
but that's not it.
So my hope throughout
this talk--
all of you guys
came and attended,
because you care about this--
my hope is to get
us, the community,
thinking about, and talking
about, and implementing
the right first
principles as we go
to take on continuous delivery.
My name is Steven Kim.
I'm an engineering manager
out of New York City.
And this is Tom Feiner.
He's a systems operations
engineer for Waze,
if you didn't guess.
And we're here to talk to you
about continuous delivery,
and a tool called
the Spinnaker, which
we want to walk you through.
Spinnaker is an open
source, multi cloud,
continuous delivery platform
developed at Netflix.
Google joined the project
some three years ago,
and, along with other members
of the community like Kenzan,
we open sourced in
October, November of 2015.
Google and Netflix, we found a
kindred spirit in one another,
in the way we go to approach
the kinds of problems
that Tom described earlier.
So what I want to do today is--
I want to share with you
four first principles.
And for each of these,
walk through how
they manifest at Waze
to ground them a bit
and give you some
tangible examples.
And then at the
end, hopefully we'll
have enough time we'll
walk through a simple demo.
The first principle is
immutable infrastructure
as Tom talked about.
It means that once you deploy
something, you don't change it.
When there's change, you
rebuild it up from the host up,
or the container up,
and then you tear down
the old one altogether.
How many of you guys have not
heard of immutable servers
or immutable infrastructures?
OK, great.
So it's widely out there.
Why do we want to do this?
Why is immutable
infrastructure important?
We want our process of building,
and testing and deploying
and validating to be as
deterministic as possible.
We know that across
environments there
is a lack of permaticity where
there are configuration drifts.
And, as you go and deploy and
promote move from environment
to environment,
that things changed.
And just because you know that
it worked in one environment--
whether it be your
developer local workstation
or in a non-production staging
or stress environment--
there's still a lot
out there through which
things can go wrong
from that promotion
to the last production stage.
So we want to go to
minimize changes slipping in
as we go to move up the runway.
And here's the way it works.
In practice, you bake.
So every time you
have a change, you
bake an image using Packer
or, for those of you who
are using configuration
management software like Puppet
and Chef, you run that
as much as you can.
And then you bake
it into an image.
So in GCP, it's
Google GCE images.
And then, at deploy time, you
go ahead and dole those out
into GCE instances.
So for those of you who are
from the container world,
this seems really
familiar, right?
Because it's the same thing.
You take your
application binaries,
you dependent runtime stacks.
You find them in a
Dockerfile, package up you
configuration file into
a Docker image using
GCR build, which we
announced earlier last week,
or your favorite service
such as Docker Hub or Quay.
And you go ahead and create
Docker container images.
And then you go ahead
and instantiate them
using, for example, Kubernetes
scheduler into pods or whatnot.
So there's some other
benefits as well
to immutable infrastructure.
If you remember, one
of the early messages
about the public
cloud was elasticity.
Elasticity had to do with
long-time window elasticity
that you don't have to go ahead
and buy upfront and then eat
the costs, but it also had to do
with responsiveness to demand--
spiky traffic, for example.
Well, for those of us who
might, for example, instantiate
an instance of VM, run your
Chef or Puppet scripts on it,
if that Puppet script takes 20
minutes or an hour and a half,
you're not taking
advantage of elasticity.
The demand has
come, and it's gone.
So there's some
other side effects
like that where you have
faster start-up times.
You can respond to demand much
quicker in traffic spikes.
And also, it opens
up opportunities
to take advantage of things like
deployment strategies that are
very particular to the cloud.
So immutable infrastructure
is an example at Waze
that Tom gave.
It was somewhat rhetorical, but
I think you guys get the idea.
The second practice
is around the use
of deployment strategies.
There are a lot
of tools out there
that people can use to
go ahead and deploy out
the infrastructure and
deploy changes to code.
Jenkins is a popular one.
But I started by saying it can't
be just about orchestration.
And deployment strategies
is an example of this.
So we're talking about
deployment strategies that
can specifically take
advantage of some
of what you get in the cloud.
So let's walk through a couple.
Whoop, wrong button.
A simple first one
is called Red/black,
some people also
call it Blue/green.
And it's the notion that you
have a production cluster, V1,
and then you have a V1.1, and
you basically create a whole
new stack running that.
And after it's been
validated through health
checks, for whatever
your criteria might be,
you cut over traffic.
The advantage here is that
if something goes wrong,
you can quickly cut back.
There are some
disadvantages as, obviously,
2Xing the amount of
infrastructure and resources
required to go
ahead and do this.
But this is a simple example
where if something goes wrong,
you can go out and
very quickly cut back.
An evolution of
this is something
that we're calling
rolling red/black.
And it's the notion that
you can go ahead and define
incrementality of traffic
percentage cut-overs
with validation
gates in between.
And so we can simply say
1%, 5%, 25%, 50%, and 100%,
and between each cut over to the
next percentage incrementality,
you can go ahead and
set a validation gate.
So it might be a
pipeline that you
run which might be very robust.
Or it might be a simple smoke
test, or a functional probe.
And it also has
the continuous take
on the advantage
of Red/black, which
is if something ever goes wrong,
rolling back is immediate.
Another evolution of that
from there is Canary.
And Canary is a different
way to do the validation
gates in between the
percentage roll-outs.
But it takes a slightly
different approach.
Rather than using functional
tests or probe or smoke tests,
we go to look at a
set of measurements
which are much more
common regardless
of what your application is.
So we look at
underlying metrics.
So obviously things like
CPU and memory profiling,
but also latency, response
codes, error rates.
And you take all
these, and you create
a weight by which
you go and say,
a certain Canary
score is acceptable.
And that Canary score
also takes into effect
about an acceptable deviation
of that Canary score
or the performance
characteristics
between your previous version
and your current version.
So here's what it
means, test coverage
is always a cat-and-mouse game.
Test coverage is at 80% today.
Every CodeCommit will go to the
lower that has test coverage.
It goes in that direction.
So with Canary, you can
actually go ahead and say, well,
no matter what
we're rolling out,
we're going to look
at a different set
of characteristics that
are common to applications.
So with that, let's go ahead
and ask Tom to go ahead
and talk about what
that looks like at Waze.
TOM FEINER: So 10
years ago, the cloud
did not exist, at least
not as it does today.
Back then, most companies
ran their own infrastructure.
And, from what I've heard in
this conference, some still do.
What's up with that?
It wasn't pretty then,
and it isn't now.
No matter how hard
you tried, you
could have sent API calls
to your hosting provider
10 years ago asking
for 500 servers,
and they would have just
dismissed you as some lunatic.
Luckily, these
days, it's possible.
And, as I mentioned,
it's part of Spinnaker.
So, using deployment
strategies, it's
basically baked into Spinnaker.
And we use that all
the time at Waze.
All right.
This is how it looks like.
Oh, I'm sorry.
In a large system,
as Steven mentioned,
it's usually impossible to
test everything in advance.
So we also use a Canary stage.
It's not fancy like
the one Netflix uses,
but it does the job.
It looks like this.
Basically, you have
a production system
running with 100% of
traffic flowing to it.
You then run version
two in a Canary
and send a tiny bit
of traffic to it.
You then run a Canary
analysis on each
and every API of that server.
So for each API, we test
for errors, latencies,
and number of requests.
We perform a relative compare
against the production group.
If it all works fine, we blow
that up to a production scale
and send 50% of traffic
to the new group,
but still 50% of
traffic to the old one.
We then run the
Canary analysis again,
this time expecting a
very similar behavior
between the two groups.
If there's any
significant difference,
we can easily roll back by
just shifting traffic back
to the old group, and
debugging, and then destroying
the old one.
But if everything's fine, then
we just disable the old group
and eventually destroy it.
STEVEN KIM: The third first
principle is automation.
So automation promotes
a consistency.
And a repeatability,
a consistency,
is important both in
success and failure modes.
When things are failing, you
need a consistency of failure
to be able to do
root cause analysis.
What really sucks is when
it fails in different ways
every single time.
And success, a
successful consistency
promotes maturity of process
that you can go and build
on top of.
And so it's about
identifying and putting
in mitigating measures,
without losing velocity.
So if you were, for example,
to go ahead and write--
a number of tools out there that
does orchestration-- and say,
step one, step two, do
this, and do a deploy.
Something fails.
You go, oh, that
can't happen again.
I'm going to go ahead
and write a mediating
measure so I can very
quickly roll back
and, say, write something else.
And the way that
this evolves, I said
at the beginning of the talk
that it slows process down,
and it becomes very difficult
to go ahead and improve
if you're slowing down
constantly, every time.
So it's difficult to improve
if you haven't instrumented.
It's difficult to-- or
less useful to instrument
if you haven't automated.
And it's hard to get to
a consistency and a scale
of information that
gets interesting enough
if you're not automating.
So let me talk about what
I mean by automation.
So top level pipelines go out
and define and execute for you
your process on how you go
ahead and release software.
So, for example, find an image
that you validated, looks good,
go ahead and deploy
using Red/black strategy,
do some rudimentary smoke
tests, wait a certain amount
of period, go ahead and scale
one down and scale it up--
all the different
deployment strategies
that we talked about before.
So this is good, but
the automation also
has to happen in a more
fine, granular form
underneath each of these steps.
So let me show you.
For that deploy to prod
Red/black [? 1 ?] stage,
here's what Spinnaker does.
For each stage, there
are a number of steps.
And so it goes and
deploys in default.
It shrinks the cluster.
It disables it, seals it down.
And then of each of those
steps, for any one given step,
there are a number of tasks
that we go ahead and perform.
So this is where it gets
really tricky, determining
the health of things.
Do we need to go forward?
Do we to go back?
Monitoring, doing
necessary cache
refreshes for us to
be able to do our job.
And then finally, for
any one of these tasks,
there are three cloud
platform level operations
that we have to go
ahead and orchestrate,
so dealing with load balancers,
association, disassociations,
target pools, and
removing instances.
And for every single one
of these minute actions--
if something goes wrong--
to be able to go out
and auto remediate.
So, this is a lot that you
would have to actually go and do
to say, we have velocity
and we have confidence.
What allows you to go
fast is confidence.
And this is the
amount of work that
is done in Spinnaker to go ahead
and promote that confidence.
And you shouldn't have to
build all of this yourself.
You should go and get behind
an open source project,
like Spinnaker, which I
will go ahead and show
you a little more later.
And so, for automation,
let's go and hear
what Waze does in a
little more detail.
TOM FEINER: By the
way, Waze really
didn't want to go
and build this stuff.
We were really happy
Spinnaker existed.
And we've actually been users
of Asgard for a few years back.
And we seamlessly transitioned
into Spinnaker from Asgard.
So it's been great.
And thanks for the
Netflix guys for doing
this, for open-sourcing.
So once deployment
pipelines are in place,
some interesting things
can start to happen.
We basically can start using
some fail-safe patterns
to limit the blast
radius of changes.
For example, at Waze, we
shard everything by geography,
obviously.
This allows pipelines
to limit the blast
radius of each upgrade.
So, for example, we can
upgrade, for a certain service,
one part of the world
completely using the Red/black
deployments, then move to a
few more parts of the world,
and eventually, worldwide.
If you're lucky and your usage
patterns are predictable,
it's good practice to
use time restriction
in deployment pipelines.
This allows us to
say, for example,
that a certain pipeline
can run between six and 12
UTC only between
Mondays and Wednesdays.
So this ensures that,
when an upgrade occurs,
it affects as few
users as possible.
And if you're really
lucky, you can
try to find a sweet spot
between the off-peak hours
and the office
hours, then you have
staff caffeinated,
and ready to go
to solve any issue that might
come up during this upgrade.
STEVEN KIM: The
fourth and final one,
which I don't think gets
talked about enough,
is operational integration.
And what operational
integration speaks to
is the notion that
the process of how
you go to release
software needs to work
hand-in-hand with how you
operationalize that software.
And that goes in
both directions,
so two simple examples.
One is that, when you're
releasing-- build, release,
and promote, and so forth--
that process is gathering and
generating a lot of information
that is germane to the scope
where you are doing root cause
analysis or defect triaging.
So, for example,
while you're trying
to go ahead and figure out
why something went out,
it's useful to go ahead
and understand, oh,
when we built that software,
what are the commits that
pertain to the change from the
last deployment to the first?
Here's the blast radius of
the code and config change.
What kind of validation
tests were run?
What were the results and
output from that test?
All this information
that is generated
at the time of doing
your deployment
becomes very, very useful
and important when you're
doing operational things.
It goes in the other
direction as well.
So you have systems
that are running.
And the information that
is gathered as your systems
run and production
are very, very useful
as you're doing your
process of doing deploys.
A simple example, as we talked
about, is Canary analysis.
Canary analysis goes and
looks at how your systems are
behaving, and it could do it at
point in time or statistically
across time to go and determine
what is the right validation
gate to go ahead and say the
system is behaving normally
as we go to promote from
one environment to another.
That make sense?
And finally, release
process inevitably
crosses multiple teams.
I know there's a lot of good
aspirations out there about
whether it's [? dev-ops ?] or
project methodology like agile
or whatever it might be, but
your process inevitably has
a lot of orchestration and
coordination that's needed
across people and teams.
And so what that means
is a Spinnaker pipeline,
for example, can help you
communicate and validate
and record hand-offs that
are necessary between teams
as you do a release process.
So to give an example
of that, back to Tom.
TOM FEINER: Thank you.
We all know real life is messy
and imperfect, especially
when you're moving fast.
During a post-mortem
meeting a few months back,
the team recognized a certain
critical mirco-service
which doesn't have
proper automated testing.
It will eventually be written,
but that will take time.
In the meantime,
we decided that we
want a person, someone
from QA, to run
a sanity after each and every
deployment to production.
Here's the problem.
Deciding to do
this is one thing,
but actually doing this
in a repeatable manner
on every single deployed
production, is easier
said than done.
People can simply forget,
tasks get shift around.
Before you know it,
recency bias kicks in,
and we're back to square one.
So here's how it looks like.
What we're going to do here is
that, basically, the developer
commits a code.
That code that starts a pipeline
in Spinnaker which initiates
a manual judgment stage.
That manual judgment stage
sends a notification to QA,
asking them to approve
this upgrade because we
need resources from them to
be there to run the sanity
and make a decision.
Once they approve-- and they
have a button to either approve
or not approve, or
they can just wait--
Spinnaker takes over, runs
a full Red/black deployment.
And once that's done,
another notification
is sent to QA, asking
to run the sanity.
Then they have an option
to either pass the sanity
and finish the automatic
deployment, or roll back.
And Spinnaker takes
care of all of this.
Basically, going forward just
means deleting the old version,
and moving backwards just
means enabling the old version
and destroying the new one.
This has been very
helpful for us.
STEVEN KIM: So we've talked
about four important ideas.
And I know it's
a lot to take in.
And we've worked hard to
make this sort of consumable
and easy to adopt and create
a ramp instead of a step.
So let me walk you through
a simple, basic demo that
takes source code, and
through Spinnaker, applying
the key principles that
we talked about, deploys
and promotes something
out to production.
Can we have the demo PC, please?
All right.
[? Simple ?] go app.
And really, it just goes and
responds with, hello world,
and the background
color is yellow.
So let's make a change--
purple.
I made it purple, right?
TOM FEINER: Yeah.
STEVEN KIM: So I'm going to go
ahead and initiate my release
process by pushing to the
release branch and source.
So what happens here
is, first of all,
right now we'll see that--
what you're looking at is
a Spinnaker--
and we see a staging environment
and a production environment.
And in the staging environment,
if we go to what's out there,
it says "hello world" in yellow.
And also in the
production environment,
it also says "hello
world" in yellow.
So far, so good.
And you'll also notice
things like the version
of the container, the
tag on it, matches.
Its the same thing
that's been promoted.
We've gone through this once.
When I committed that
code, what I have set up
is a build trigger.
This is not in
Spinnaker, but you
can go ahead and build
your containers in any way.
Docker Hub and Quay both
have build triggers.
And I set up a
trigger in GCR build
so that when there is a push to
the release branch, I go ahead
and trigger a build.
And I can use the Dockerfile
that's sitting in there,
but I want to use a feature
called GCR Build Steps which
allows me to go ahead and
build, among other things,
lean containers.
I just want to go ahead
and take a quick segue
to go ahead and talk
about this a little bit.
The notion is that instead
of-- a typical Dockerfile
looks like something like
from this base image,
pull in this source, go ahead
and build it, and then identify
an entry point.
And then that whole thing
happens in a container.
One of the challenges
there is that everything
that you needed to build it
stays with you as you go ahead
and run it-- so the SDK,
dependent packages, all
these things that you
really don't need.
It's a general notion that
how you go out and build
in a validation context
is very different than how
you might want to build for what
you actually run in production.
It's not really controversial.
And so, what you ideally like
to do is do it in two steps.
One step, I want you to go
ahead and build my binary.
And then the second step,
containerize just that binary.
So that's what I've
defined over here.
If you guys want
to look at more,
you should go ahead and
Google Container Builder.
And what you'll
see is I have the
build that happened just now.
And if I look at my Container
Registry for that service,
you'll notice that
it's like four
megabytes for that
"hello world" container.
Previously, I had built it
using the standard method,
and it is 241 megabytes.
So that's like 1 and
1/2 orders of magnitude
we're talking about there.
And it's because the Go SDK
is in that container as well
as all the different
packages that I downloaded.
OK, so back to our
normally scheduled program.
So in Spinnaker, I
go ahead and manage
the process the production
in three pipelines--
deploy to stage, validate,
and then promote to prod.
So the first stage, first
pipeline, looks like this.
The configuration is set
such that every time there
is a change to my Docker
registry, a new tag appears.
I want you to pull that down
and trigger this pipeline.
And it really has just
one stage, deploy.
And deploy-- I'll look at
the deployment details--
sends it to a stack I designated
as the staging environment.
It deploys the container
that trigger the pipeline.
And it uses the
Red/black strategy.
And what that means
is, once again,
it goes and brings up a new
[? assisted ?] Kubernetes.
So it's going to
be a replica set.
And then once it's
deemed to be healthy,
it'll cut over the load balancer
and disable the other one.
And you'll notice that I
checked on the box that
says "scale down,
replace the server
groups to zero instances."
This is a non-production
environment.
I don't have to cut
back in a hurry.
Let's save on the resources.
So that's running right now.
And you can see, once
again as I described
before, for that one deploy
stage, it's deploying,
shrinking the cluster.
Under each of those,
you can go and see
the individual tasks that
are being managed to do this.
So the next pipeline
is called validate.
And the validate pipeline
is set to trigger
when the deploy
to stage pipeline
completes successfully,
the first one that I just
showed you.
And it has two simple steps.
The first one is
a validate stage.
And this is what we call a
run job stage in Spinnaker.
And it basically allows you to
point to an arbitrary container
and run it.
And whatever the exit status
for that container is,
it'll go ahead and
proceed accordingly.
And for me, it's
actually just a simple--
I think it's a curl command.
It goes and curls the
endpoint that I specify,
which is my staging endpoint.
And if it comes back
with a 200, it'll
say it's a zero exit code.
It'll continue.
And then finally,
at that point, I
have a manual judgment stage
which notifies somebody.
And then that person
has to go and say,
yep, everything looks
good, yes, or no.
This is, by the way--
I'll take a moment real quick--
continuous delivery and
continuous deployment.
So continuous deployment
is all the way
to production automated.
And continuous
delivery typically
entails somebody being a
gate to go and say, yeah,
this is ready to go.
Finally-- actually, let me
see if that came through.
Oh, yeah, here we go.
So at this point, you'll notice
that my staging environment--
please be purple.
Please be purple.
It's purple.
TOM FEINER: Yeah!
[LAUGHTER]
STEVEN KIM: And you notice that
the container tags are also
different, right?
So it looks good.
I'm going to go
ahead and promote it.
So when I hit Continue, my third
and final pipeline will run.
And here's what that looks like.
The configuration,
as you might imagine,
is set so that
this pipeline will
trigger when the validate
pipeline completes
successfully.
And it'll do a couple of things.
First, I find the image from
the staging environment.
I know it was good.
I tested it.
I want to use that instead
of rebuilding or locating
that image otherwise.
And so I can give it
coordinates to go ahead and say
from the staging environment,
take the image from the newest
group that's out there
and give me that image.
I take that image,
and I deploy a Canary.
And for that deployment, I go
ahead and specify the Canary
environment.
I don't use any
strategies because I
don't want to manipulate
traffic in any way.
I just want to bring
something up and put it
into the same load balancer.
And I put up one instance.
So now we have the
old production as is,
at full capacity.
And then we have one instance
of the new version in a Canary
environment, both taking traffic
from the same load balancer.
So what will happen
at this point
is your users are visiting
and 1/9, or however many ever
that percentage comes out
to, will get the new version.
And you'll start gathering data.
And the idea is to start
gathering telemetry
around how well that's going.
If that looks good,
after the Canary is done,
I want you to go ahead
and notify somebody.
They'll look at the
Canary data and approve.
And then at that point, they'll
do a Red/black deployment
to production.
So it looks good.
Let's go ahead and cut over
the production environment
using Red/black to
the new version, which
will disable the old one.
But you'll notice,
or I'll point to,
that I deployed prod,
I use Red/black,
but I don't scale down the
replaced server groups.
So they're sitting
there, not taking traffic
because Red/black disabled
them, but it's sitting there.
Why?
Because if something goes wrong,
we want to able to cut over,
cut back, very, very quickly.
And we have ad hoc operations
where you can click a button,
and then it goes and rolls
back, sends traffic out
of the old one again, instantly.
And then we tear
down the Canary.
And once again, we
use locators that
say the newest server group
in the Canary environment,
go ahead and tear that down--
destroy server group stage.
And at this point,
Canary's dead.
We have just old prod, new prod.
Old prod is disabled.
Let's not be too hasty.
Let's force a two-hour
wait because at worst,
all it's doing is
tying down resources.
Then destroy that old prod.
So at this point, if I look
at where my pipelines are,
my Canary went through.
It's waiting for
manual judgment.
And if I go back to my clusters
view, here's my production.
And here is my Canary.
So I don't know what to really
expect because I've never
done this with more than me.
Everybody, pull out your phones.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
That is the production endpoint.
So, if you please navigate to
mdservice.spinnaker-test.net,
what should happen is most of
you should get a yellow page.
And about one out
of every 10 of you
should be getting a purple page.
So once you have it loaded up,
can you guys raise your phones
and point it toward me?
TOM FEINER: Oh, yeah.
It worked!
STEVEN KIM: Oh, my god.
TOM FEINER: Oh!
Well, you can't see it, but--
STEVEN KIM: All right.
I'll go ahead and
point that over to--
TOM FEINER: Some are
purple and some are yellow.
STEVEN KIM: And so at this
point, it's going to look good.
Canary looked good.
It showed up purple.
I'm going hit Continue.
And it will proceed on to
go and destroy the old prod.
Is that pretty
straightforward to you
guys about how that would work?
Now a couple of things that are
important that happened there.
It was all automated.
There was every opportunity
where we recorded
every step that was taken.
It followed a process
that we defined.
And, really, at the point where
we get comfortable with things
that can go wrong, we
can start cutting out
those manual approval stages.
And we can get much
smarter than this.
This is a demo scenario.
If you ask what Waze is
doing with Spinnaker,
or what Netflix is
or a number of
other organizations,
they're doing far more
sophisticated things.
Like, for example,
Waze is using Spinnaker
to go ahead and do fleet
upgrades of base OS
based on pipelines that
go ahead and handle
all of this for them.
So, as I mentioned, we
open-sourced in 2015.
And we open-sourced with
GCE and EC2 providers.
As I said, Spinnaker
is multi-cloud.
And a Cloud Foundry
provider came out there
in beta at the time.
And we had Red/black strategy
and some basic support.
In 2016, we were headed
down development,
and we introduced the
Kubernertes provider.
The Azure provider
joined in beta.
Microsoft joined.
OpenStack provider--
and, really, those people
from the community who
are building these things,
some of them are here
in the room right now.
So thank you very much.
We added authentication
and authorization support
through OAuth 2, Google Groups,
GitHub team, SAML, [INAUDIBLE].
We added much more robust
support for load balancers,
layer 3 and 4, layer 7
HTP, internal SSL support.
We integrated a
Stackdriver logging.
So we're trying to make this
operationally ready for you
guys to go ahead and take on.
And support for things like
autoscaling and autohealing.
And also we're
beginning to reach out
into other popular systems
in the ecosystem like Consul
for doing things like
discovery and health readiness.
And in 2017, what
we're working on
is we're going to be adding
an App Engine provider.
And so that's actually
pretty much done.
We're ready to start
taking alpha testers.
So I'll tell you how to go
and reach out to us later.
We're beginning on formal
support for Canary Strategy.
That's available
in the OSS realm.
So Google and Netflix are
working very closely on this.
And we expect to be at a pretty
good point in the latter half
of this year with that.
We're going to be introducing
rolling Red/black strategy.
That's also at a very
good place already.
Another major effort
is declarative CD.
And you can look at
it as config as code,
but it's really more than that.
It's more of a holistic
look at when we go and say,
here's an application, so far we
think about binary and config.
But also we want to go to make
that bundle be defined as,
and here's how you should deploy
me, and manage me, upgrade me,
and so forth.
So what that means is
that as you have Spinnaker
in your organization, you can
have application development
teams who should be
self-sufficient, define all
their artifacts as code,
check it into a repository,
and have Spinnaker enact
that on their behalf.
Spinnaker is a complex system--
many micro services,
lots of configuration,
and we recognize that this is
a high friction to adoption.
So in about a month, we'll
be introducing formally
versioned releases.
And so we will run the
full, synthetic transaction
integration test for
you to go ahead and say,
[? here ?] is the combination
of different services
that we have validated, and
work for these providers.
So we can look and know
what you're getting.
And also, we'll be done with
a Spinnaker configuration
management tool that allows you
to install, upgrade, configure,
and validate your Spinnaker
environment as well.
There's a lot of documentation
and doubt there right now
currently, but we
think that this tool
is going to be a necessity for
people to really adopt and be
successful with this.
And finally, we're
going to be filling
in operational monitoring for
the Spinnaker instance itself,
so that if what's
deploying your software
might have performance issues,
or something goes down,
that somebody can
be notified of that.
And much more.
Really, there's actually
some really exciting stuff
that you'll hear from us.
It's not little things.
It's pretty cool things.
So spinnaker.io is our website.
And we develop out in the open,
so if you go to the Spinnaker
GitHub organization, you can
see everything that we're doing.
The best way to get engaged
is our Slack channel.
We are a community
that's 2,000 strong--
heavy participation.
People are helping
each other out.
It's a great place to come, get
introduced into the community,
ask for any level of help.
People are extremely friendly
and helpful over there.
And also, just I'll
mention as a shortcut,
if you want to quickly get
an instance of Spinnaker out
for yourself to
play around today,
go to cloud.google.com/launcher,
search for Spinnaker,
and you can, in one click, get
an instance of Spinnaker up
that you can go and
start working with.
There are also a
set of code labs
on spinnaker.io that you
can go ahead and look at.
That's how you can go
ahead and get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]